on this Thursday night the dire need for
medical supplies for our health care
workers the prime minister says help is
on the way in the coming days we will be
receiving millions more items who is
helping and what are they sending Plus
new details on travelers who land in
Canada and could be quarantined New York
overloaded and underprepared 9/11 was
nothing compared to this the extreme
measures medical workers there are
forced to take beefing up border
security why the US president thinks
Canadians are a threat during this
pandemic and mounting pressure to plank
the curve were forced to treat and learn
at the same time successes and failures
in the fight against kovat 19
global national with Donna freezin
[Music]
good evening and thanks for joining us
there are lots of developments again
tonight here's where we start the Kovach
19 pandemic has reached another alarming
milestone the number of global
infections has now surpassed half a
million and here's another shock the
United States now has the most cases of
any country in the world more than
83,000 which means it has surpassed
China and Italy in Canada more than
4,000 people have now tested positive
and though social distancing is expected
to help in the coming weeks right now
the virus is still spreading fast in the
face of that frontline workers around
the world are running short of
protective equipment in Canada some
hospitals are already rationing masks
and worn a severe shortage of things
like masks gloves and other protective
supplies is imminent today Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau promised help is
on the way
in the coming days we will be receiving
millions more items that are necessary
right across the country back in
February it was Canada that was helping
others the government sent 16 tons of
personal protective equipment to China
when cases of the virus were surging
there now it's the Chinese who are
preparing to send us supplies our chief
political correspondent David akin has
new details tonight when China was
scrambling to deal with the initial
outbreak of kovat 19 Canada's stepped up
to help sending all kinds of medical
equipment to who Bay Province we
recognized from the very beginning that
this is a global crisis that requires
global cooperation and response if we
are to keep all of us safe indeed and
China is thinking along the same lines
because now that Canada is scrambling to
contain its own outbreak China is
stepping up and is preparing to send
Canada millions of items ventilators
surgical masks shields and so on in the
meantime the Canada Revenue Agency or
CRA is revamping its website to accept
applications for the new Canada
emergency relief benefit that will pay
those losing income because of kovat 19
up to $2,000 a month for four months
it's a massive job
the CRA expects as many as four million
Canadians
to apply when the CRA web portal is up
and running sometime around April the
6th the Prime Minister and premiers also
hammered home the new mandatory
self-isolation rules that are now in
effect for those coming in to Canada all
travelers if you're coming home
you must go directly home and self
isolate I think it's critical that
people fully understand that that is not
stopping at the grocery store that is
not stopping at the post office that is
going directly home and isolating for 14
days and there are consequences if you
do not comply with these instructions
you could face serious fines and even
prison time
so David a tougher message again today
but what about travelers who arrive on
planes or at a land crossing who are
sick what's happening to them yeah lots
on that today well those who are sick
and can make it to their home in their
own private vehicle they can do so but
they have to register with public health
authorities and they are going to get
regular visits to make sure they are
staying in isolation for 14 days now
those that arrive at the border with
symptoms who can't make it home in their
own vehicles and this would include
those who arrive on an international
flight who need to make a connecting
flight to somewhere else where they're
gonna stay right where they are and they
will end up in a government quarantine
facility likely an airport hotel for 14
days
right now though very few travelers in
that situation dr. Teresa Tam said today
is just one person in Vancouver and one
couple in Quebec in that situation Donna
David akin in Ottawa thank you here's
where Canadian infection numbers stand
tonight more than 600 new cases have
been reported across the country Quebec
reported the biggest spike 290 new cases
bringing the total in that province to
more than 1,600 in Ontario there are now
858 confirmed cases of those 20 people
are on ventilators in the hospital in
total 39 people have died but many of
the most recent cases are in people who
have returned from travel including from
the US which now has the most cases in
the world
yet the American president is
considering sending troops to the border
with Canada to protect that country from
us our Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes
Vincent broke the story Mercedes with
his surgeon cases in the US all the
people dying there how is putting troops
at the Canadian border supposed to help
well Donna a lot of Canadians and
Americans question how it would help
what I'm being told by sources is that
the u.s. president and officials in the
White House believed that it would help
to detect people illegally crossing the
border from Canada into the United
States now there's not a lot of people
who do that compared to the number who
crossed from the u.s. to Canada but with
the kovat 19 crisis President Donald
Trump and his officials are saying that
they don't want migrants with quote
unquote
diseases as a you as a leaked Border
Patrol memo called it coming into the
United States so they want to deploy the
military along the border to help make
sure that doesn't happen
President Trump was asked about this at
his press conference today and here's
what he had to say about why he's
thinking about deploying troops along
the border well we have very strong
deployments on the southern border as
you know with Mexico and we had some
troops up in Canada but I'll find out
about that I guess it's equal justice to
a certain extent you know we have a lot
of things coming in from Canada we have
trade some illegal trade that we don't
like and we don't like steel coming
through our border that's been dumped
Donna a lot of people on both sides of
the board are very concerned about this
proposal historically the border has
been non militarized that's something
that Prime Minister Justin Trudeau said
he thinks is in everyone's best interest
Deputy Prime Minister Krishna Freeland
using much stronger words saying she
believes that this would be unnecessary
and damaging to the relationship I'm
told that Canada has been pushing back
very hard against this in private and so
have a lot of officials in Washington
who think this will be damaging to an
important relationship with an important
ally Mercedes do we have any idea what
the US troops would do near the Canadian
border so this would be under a thousand
troops and they'd be deployed about
thirty kilometers from the border they'd
be using remote sensor technology to
pick up people who are crossing the
border then they'd feed that information
to the u.s. Border Patrol
agents who'd be able to go out and
introduce people they're not allowed to
enforce laws themself as US troops but
they can provide that military
intelligence to border agents to try to
capture people who are crossing
illegally Donna
all right Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa
Thanks a new report on the global impact
of kovat 19 spells out in staggering
terms where this could all be headed
experts at Imperial College London who
do disease mapping and modeling and
advise governments project this and
brace yourself the numbers are huge in
the absence of any interventions this
virus would have infected seven billion
people they say and killed 40 million
mitigating the spread with interventions
which so many countries are doing and
the number of deaths could be reduced by
half to 20 million still health care
systems in every country will be
overwhelmed especially in poorer
countries it's only by suppressing the
spread through testing isolating
infected people and their contacts and
strict social distancing that the report
says the death toll will be reduced
further and here's the part that's most
crucial in this report delays in
implementing strategies to suppress
transmission will lead to worse outcomes
and fewer lives saved
well parts of the American health care
system are already overwhelmed according
to John Hopkins University there are now
more than 83,000 confirmed cases in the
u.s. that is the war most in the world
and more than 1,200 Americans have now
died the pandemic has shut down large
parts of that country's economy a record
3.3 million Americans filed unemployment
claims last week that's nearly five
times the previous record New York State
is the epicenter and it is clear now
political leaders there waited too long
to take decisive action to limit the
spread
Jackson prosecco reports New York's
hospitals are already past the breaking
point
9/11 was nothing compared to this they
just keep coming and they're all ages
don't delude yourself into thinking only
the old will die doctors and nurses
overcome by the sheer number of
coronavirus patients as the epidemic
ravages America's largest city hell
biblical I kid you not at Elmhurst
Hospital where 13 patients died in a
single day the line for coronavirus
tests stretches around the block the New
York Times obtained video from inside
where staff are under protected and
overwhelmed our refrigerated truck has
been brought in to store bodies the
frustrating thing about all of this is
it really just feels like it's too
little too late like we knew we knew it
was coming at other hospitals nurses
wear garbage bags as gowns as supplies
of protective equipment run low tents
have been set up to serve as makeshift
morgues almost any scenario that is
realistic will overwhelm the capacity of
the current health care system the
state's governor continues to plead for
more ventilators and supplies from the
federal government but there's stiff
competition the problem isn't just that
the cases are growing every day it is
that they're growing rapidly every day
New Orleans could run out of ventilators
within a week every ICU bed is taken at
Atlanta's four main hospitals the stress
on the system from kovat 19 now risks
the lives of other critically ill
patients if they're unable to because
the system is otherwise overloaded there
will be an increase in morbidity and
increase in deaths the White House is
now working on a plan to categorize
various states as high medium or low
risk in an effort to reopen parts of the
country the unintended consequence of
that though is that one state may now
discriminate against residents from
another we're already seeing it happen
Rhode Island says it will pull over New
Yorkers and Texas says it will force
people from New York and New Jersey into
quarantine Donna Jackson prosecco in
Washington thanks in this pandemic Italy
still has the highest death toll more
than 8,000 people have died there Spain
is second more than 4,000 lives lost in
that country about 14 percent of those
infected in those countries are health
care workers doctors and nurses are
among the dead as crystal de Manson
reports the scale of all of this is hard
to grasp it is the most grim of
deliveries truck after truck dropping
off bodies at an Olympic sized ice rink
turn mork in Spain more than 4,000
people have died and many more lives are
on the line Spain's King Felipe toured a
new military hospital he hopes it will
ease the heroic and intense daily battle
being waged by doctors and nurses a
battle shared by those in Italy despite
the situation in Spain Italy is still
the epicentre of the European outbreak
infections surged again and police in
Rome ramped up spot checks fines for
breaking the lockdown went up to four
thousand euros this virus is very
dangerous if you remember we have been
saying for more than two months now this
is this virus is public enemy number one
that enemy is still spreading daily we
must look out for each other
we must pull each other through this
because if there's one thing that is
more contagious than this virus it is
love and compassion compassion also
means financial support 37 billion euro
is on the table to help members of the
European Union get through this health
crisis crystal de Manson Global News
London
coming up the vital lessons Canada can
learn from other countries as Canada
deals with a surge in kovat 19 cases we
can learn from countries who are ahead
of us in this outbreak extensive testing
isolating those who are sick and their
contacts and physical distancing are
crucial to suppressing the spread of the
virus wait too long to do that and it's
too late
is Eric Sorensen reports this is a
crucial time for Canada Germany's
chancellor learned weeks ago the
importance of keeping apart staying off
the streets was adopted early in Germany
and testing is big while Canada reached
a hundred and twenty thousand tests this
week Germany is testing a hundred and
twenty thousand every week Bahamas flew
a [ __ ] we detected it early says this
senior health official because we tested
it early 43,000 Germans have contracted
kovat 19 but with remarkably low
mortality one death for every 200 cases
half the rate in this country Canadian
doctors are learning from countries with
even just a few more weeks experience we
have set up a specific social media
group where we exchange any new
information that we come across but I
think we're in a dynamic situation where
we're forced to treat and learn at the
same time it's a crucial time for this
country to stay on top of the outbreak
the critical period of days is measured
after a country reaches 100 confirmed
cases Canada reached that date on March
the 11th since then the cases have
surged past a thousand two thousand
towards three thousand than the curve is
bending upwards Japan has done a better
job than most countries of flattening
the curve attributed by some to a mask
wearing obedient population other
countries have been at this much longer
Canada has a fraction of the number of
cases of China which is over 80,000
South Korea managed to bend the curve
down with a massive testing program to
below 10,000 Italy didn't get started
soon enough same thing for Spain and
maybe most worrying of all is the United
States all of these are arcing upwards
which suggests that cases are doubling
more quickly the goal for Canada then is
to get Canadians to stay home
and Bend that curve downward over these
next critical weeks whether Japanese
diligence or South Korean thoroughness
being rigorous makes a difference the
path ahead for Canada remains uncertain
our pandemic infection rate is still
growing exponentially in Ontario and and
in all of Canada over the next two weeks
hopefully we'll start to see that the
rate of increase is slowing which would
indicate that the social distancing
measures are working Canadians may yet
need to take more measures but we have
the experience of other countries to
show what works and what doesn't
Eric Sorenson Global News Toronto
survival on services still ahead expert
data on kovat 19's screen time
the first case of kovat 19 was confirmed
in Canada
two months ago since then a whole lot
has changed throughout this crisis we've
been trying to ease some of your fears
and your confusion by putting your
questions to the experts Jeff simple has
more answers for you tonight Jeff Donna
Canada's health minister says she
expects between 30 and 70 percent of
Canadians will become infected with
kovat 19 and of those cases around 20
percent will be serious and may require
hospitalization with the average stay be
in the ICU Global News took a tour of
this intensive care unit where hospital
staff are bracing for a rush of kovat 19
patients some may need to be
hospitalized for months the sickest
patients with covin 19 have what looks
like pneumonia on both sides of the
lungs that require a lot of oxygen to be
given around 200 Canadians who were
infected with kovat 19 have now
recovered released from hospital leading
some to wonder whether they might now be
immune if someone recovered from Kovan
19 there's a chance to have bars again
that's a really good question that we
just don't have the answer to yet there
haven't been any confirmed cases of
someone catching kovat 19 twice but some
viruses such as influenza mutate rapidly
which is why people can catch the flu
again and again you know every year is a
slightly different virus that we're
tackling with and we don't know enough
yet about this new corona virus if it
mutates as quickly as influenza hi my
name is story I'm calling for Vancouver
I have some questions about the corona
virus I want to know how long it lives
on services such as cell phones tablets
a recent study found that kovat 19 can
survive on plastic surfaces like a
smartphone case for up to three days
while similar viruses have been known to
survive on glass surfaces for
- for days your phone is about 18 times
dirtier than like a public restroom
toilet seat this Toronto company is
scrambling to supply hospitals with
these smart phone sanitizers the
microwave like devices blast bacteria
and viruses with intense ultraviolet
light they've sold twice as many units
last month than all of last year now if
you can't afford your own UV machine you
can also clean your smart phone with one
of these a wipe with at least 70%
alcohol and if you don't have one of
these Donna you can also just wet a
cloth with some soap soap and water
Jeff's simple in Toronto thank you the
latest tool in fighting the pandemic
next some promising research coming out
of New York the race is on across the
world to come up with rapid test kits
treatments and a vaccine for kovat 19 as
Heather Urich's west reports they could
be game changers in this pandemic
researchers in New York have
significantly advanced the science that
will help the world fight back against
kovat 19 it's important because we can
now actually identify individuals who
already have had Cohen 19 and are immune
to it when people get infected the
immune system reacts and the immune
system produces what we call antibodies
and these are chemical substances in
your body that can attack the invading
German a team at the Icahn School of
Medicine at Mount Sinai has developed a
blood test that can detect whether
people have antibodies to kovat 19 in
their blood it's a critical development
for a number of reasons it'll give us a
handle on who was exposed and who wasn't
so if this virus comes back in a second
or third wave will know who is
unprotected and who's protected we know
that not everyone infected with kovat 19
has symptoms so an antibody test is the
only way of determining who's been
exposed and who's now immune this is a
vital tool particularly when it comes to
identifying those with immunity within
the health system these people can
actually treat critically ill patients
on they can treat patients who are
contagious
so they don't have any risk of infection
having this test may also help with
treatment some patients who have
recently recovered from kovat 19 have
blood rich with antibodies and this
blood known as convalescent plasma can
be used to treat up to two other
patients who may be critically ill on
Thursday New York's Mount Sinai Hospital
announced it's now using the therapy to
treat kovat 19 patients in its ICU it's
very exciting as a urologist to be able
to contribute in a time like this the
New York researchers are now sending the
protein used for their tests two labs
around the world hopeful their work can
lead to the next big advancement in the
race to stop the spread of kovat 19
Heather Eric's West Global News congri
and that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna Friesen tonight we
leave you with a nightly salute to
health care workers in Vancouver at 7:00
p.m. people step on their balconies and
porches to cheer and clap and bang pots
and pans a way to thank healthcare
workers and a noisy and loving way to
say we're in this together thanks for
watching and take care of yourselves
[Music]